noch 12 Stunden am Ende von Seven fünf
Teilnehmer die vollen sieben Tage
durchgestanden in dieser Folge zeigen
wir Ihre Abholung im Extended Cut ihr
erstes Essen und erste medizinische
Versorgung unmittelbar nach ihre
Abholung haben wir außerdem mit jedem
Teilnehmer ein Interview geführt wo sie
über ihre Erfahrungen größten Erfolge
aber auch Schwierigkeiten mit uns
geredet haben diese sieben Videos werden
ab morgen in täglichen Abständen auf
diesem Kanal hochgeladen über die Links
in der Videobeschreibung kommt ihr
direkt dorthin oder schaut einfach auf
dem Kanal und jetzt viel Spaß mit dem
Finale von Seven vs white während
[Musik]
irgendwann heute im Verlauf des Tages
ein Boot auftauchen es waren wirklich
geile 7 Tage das ist meine Insel bis zum
Schluss
die größte Herausforderung meines Lebens
[Musik]
herzlichen Glückwunsch
herzlichen Dank ich glückwunsch
[Musik]
ja damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet
ey ohne Scheiß Schweden dagegen Urlaub
sagte dieses das war sieben Tage Hölle
7 Tage lang ausschließlich komplett nass
es war sieben Tage kein Feuer 7 Tage
lang nur viel Zeit die ganze Zeit in der
fressen 7 Tage lang kein selbst wo du
irgendwie mal deine Ruhe hast
oder aber gut haben sie doch geschafft
geil war viel Kopfsache aber ging er hat
schon Durchfall hat ja auch erstmal von
Tag 55 am Arsch also ich sag mal so ich
glaube ich hat alles dabei was man sagen
kann bis auf irgendein andere alles ich
bin umgezogen ich habe drei verschiedene
Lagerplatz ich bin abgesoffen da drüben
es war komplett
[Musik]
komplett wild ey aber die wichtigste
Frage ich weiß nicht ob du mir das schon
beantworten kannst oder darfst
wollen wir die anderen jetzt noch ab
okay ich habe gestern schon ein kleines
Fahrt gemacht ich habe ganz am Anfang in
Deutschland habe ich gesagt sechs von
sieben kommen durch man muss aber auch
dazu sagen dass ich mir alles komplett
anders vorgestellt habe wirklich
Location Wetter Resourcen vorher machen
ich habe einen Haufen vorbereitungsvideo
von tropical Videos gesehen das hat
nichts mit dem zu tun was wir machen die
sind alle irgendwo im urlaubspaare die
habe ich das Gefühl nicht so Regenzeit
in einem geilen Sandstrand mit überall
Heim das hier ist komplett das Screen
hell einfach gewesen ich glaube ich habe
glaube ich gestern gesagt dass vier von
sieben durch sind also otto ist auf
jedenfalls noch drin aber sonst boah
keine Ahnung aber ich muss sagen es war
echt hart es war immer wieder richtig
richtig hart also ich lag Stunde lang
komplett im Regen ich Strand im Regen
ich wurde komplett zerbissen Donner
junge ich habe noch nie solche Gewitter
erlebt das war völlig krank über mir
mein Brust wer hat einfach vibriert und
ich dachte mir so also jemand der das
Auto Leben nicht kennt der Scheiß sich
ein der geht der drücken Knopf und nach
dem Motto ich meine habe ich doch noch
nicht erlebt aber ich dachte mir immer
ganz ehrlich wenn ich im Blitz schon
gesehen habe dann habe ich überlebt also
passt alles ja keine Ahnung ich weiß es
nicht ich habe keine Ahnung vielleicht
damit ihr das ein bisschen Einhorn
können verstehen können ne das ist eine
riesen Flussmündung und das was ihr
gerade seht ist ja so ein so ein außen
Flussbereich und der ist bei Flut bis
dahin alles ist alles unter Wasser hier
es gibt quasi nur Dschungel wenn die
Fluter sonst nichts das wusste ich aber
am Anfang nicht habe erstmal mein erstes
Lager drüber aufgebaut pro wieso stehen
alles gut hat das zweite Lager auch da
drüben aufgebaut plötzlich ich liege in
dem Lager drin die Wellen unter mir rein
Bam Bam über Wasser ich mache einfach
Waterworld auf einmal denken wir so
scheiße fangen an in der Nacht alles
abzuräumen durchs Wasser durchzuwarten
irgendwie im Dschungel da reinzugehen
und mir ein neues Lager aufzubauen für
das war völlig krank und mein Shelter
war einfach nicht dich hat immer immer
durchgeregt und ich habe ausgebessert
ich habe gemacht keine Chance das ist
alles was ich hatte die letzten sieben
Tage und vielleicht willst du meine
Kleine Nahaufnahme von meiner silbernen
Klinge machen
nicht vorhanden komplett verrostet
komplett angegammelt und wenn du noch
eine andere Aufnahme machen willst die
Scheide komplett verschimmelt weil nass
von Tag eins nur nassen nass ja die
letzten sieben Tage hat hier meine
Kleidung und das hier und natürlich
Kamera Technik erste Technik und sowas
das ist auch nicht so schön wie man sich
das vorstellt mit irgendwie äh keine
Ahnung ach idyllisch und das ist einfach
eine Müllhaufen ist das hier eigentlich
jede Kokosnuss ist vergammelt stinkt
sogar
ja so aber jetzt kommen wir in mein
Zimmer ich habe sogar no joke ich habe
gestern aufgeräumt ich habe einen
richtigen kleinen Weg gemacht
ach und übrigens dieser Bereich ist
normalerweise auch komplett unter Wasser
wenn es regnet weil von da oben sich ein
riesenfluss bildet ja das ist mein
kleiner nicht dichter Dschungel Shelter
mit einer kleinen
[Musik]
jede Nacht 12 Stunden lang schwarz jeden
Tag Regen so wirklich herrlich Urlaub
zum Nachmachen ich kann sich nur
empfehlen tatsächlich hatte ich auch
viel viel mehr vor Reise bauen fischbär
und Nahrungsbeschaffung und sowas aber
das Thema Feuer ey sei mir nicht böse
aber wie zur Hölle soll ich hier und
vorher machen es regnet von früh bis
abends und wenn es nicht regnet dann
kommt die Flut hier hoch und alles
Peitsch alles was man da draußen
hier im Regenwald ist auch klitschnass
ich habe keine Ahnung wie man das
schaffen soll in der Regenzeit hier mal
easy und Feuer anzumachen ich schaffe es
nicht hier und dann habe ich manchmal so
Projekte die habe ich nachts gemacht
und habe einfach in stundenlanger
Feinarbeit die komplett auseinander
gefesselt und zu schnüren verarbeitet
einfach damit ich nachts irgendeine
Scheiße zu tun aber nicht pennen konnte
und dann kam ich dazu dass ich ja so
viel Schnüre gar nicht mehr brauche
deswegen mache ich mit dem Halskette
drauf
richtige Löcher in meinem Fuß einfach
drin
ah hier das ist übrigens mein
mitbringsel-challenge Tag 1 für die
Community das ist eine Miniatur Bett auf
dem ich sieben Tage lang geschlafen habe
so ganz geil die Techniken sie so eine
kleine Hängematte gewesen
wie ist der Plan Abfahrt okay
[Musik]
war noch nicht einmal mehr trocken die
Schuhe sind einfach von Anfang an nass
ich habe sie gestern als so heiß war
einmal trocken bekommen Regen nass
[Musik]
7 Tagen mal wieder klares Wasser ich
habe nur
ich würde sagen noch eine Skala von 1
bis 10 die menschenfeindlich ist das
alles hier
deutlich schlimmeres wird jetzt eher mit
Schweden vergleichen weil da habe ich
halt die die Erfahrung dazu ich sag mal
mit sieben Tagen komplett in der Wüste
bis ist das viel viel menschenfeindlich
aus oder wenn du irgendwo in den Bergen
bist wo nichts ist nur kack auch
Menschen bei dir aber im Vergleich zu
spät war das schon echt beschissen mies
und ist mir auch noch aufgefallen als
Vater für mich es macht natürlich ein
riesen Unterschied ob sie oder ein
Gegenstände ja ich sag mal so ein riesen
Problem viel Zeug hält die Maske dabei
mit dem Gegenstand also so viele Fächer
den ganzen Tag und früh bis abends nur
ich habe teilweise meine Boxen bitte mit
Schlamm reingeschmiert komplett
es ging nur den ganzen Tag ja kommt
jetzt Schlammpackung gestern nicht
komplett hier rumgelaufen alles ähm oder
wenn solche schönen feuerstar gab und
Feuer zu machen und braucht zu erzeugen
die fernzuhalten wenn du einen Tat
gehabt hättest dann wirst Du mal
irgendwann 7 Tage nass
aber hast du Feuer
danke danke herzlichen Glückwunsch es
war leichter gedacht man
mega gut ist tatsächlich Spaß gemacht
also ein richtig Spaß gemacht ich habe
den Platz lieben gelernt dafür dass es
angeblich so ein Scheiß Spots ist sein
sollte ist alles mega bis auf Sandstrand
ist alles da und das cool ist ich habe
hier direkt rechts immer groß ist immer
groben durch und bin mir sehr sehr
sicher das Krokodil gesehen habe dreimal
ich habe einen Tag einen Shelter gemacht
mir für wenn die Sonne brutzelt dass ich
nicht verbrenne und jetzt großartignet
ist so eine kleine Mini mini-höhle links
die hat doch die ersten drei Tage nachts
funktioniert und dann kam das Hochwasser
immer mehr und dann habe ich hier oben
wo dieser große Baum den Ober dieser
Klippe stehen ist da direkt einen dran
mein Adler Nest was auch immer schön
Blick hier komplett drauf habe der Mega
ist alles mit Bambus teilen aber ich
habe den Shelter nicht den oberen nicht
wasserdicht gebaut sondern einfach nur
Bambus zum hinlegen weil ich hatte ja
unten den wasserdicht ist hat auch
funktioniert oder wenn es regnet
heute Nacht war ich mit Unterhose lag
ich da im strömenden Regen weil unten
war gerade Hochwasser ich konnte also
nicht meine Hülle und oben hatte ich
nichts zur Sache gebaut aber es war
trotzdem geil geil Aufnahmen auf jeden
Fall ansonsten keine Probleme gehabt die
7 Tage Bock macht na klar das Bock
gemacht aber sowas von Bock gemacht ich
habe auch extra ich habe aber ersten Tag
eine Kokosnuss gegessen und dann dachte
ich mir an der weiß was du machst das
komplett ohne Essen das heißt ja aber ab
dem zweiten Tag nichts mehr gegessen
also im ersten Tag nur die eine
Kokosnuss und dann nur Wasser getrunken
hinten aus dem Becher fertig nicht
gefilter gar nichts
ich könnte ruhig noch ein bisschen
härter sein aber ich will die Frage
nicht so hoch nein beim geil war hammer
wirklich schön ganz ganz toll hat
richtig Bock gemacht geile Tages
challenges da bin ich sehr gespannt wie
alle abgestanden haben tatsächlich war
einer bin ich sicher dass ich sehr gut
war und bei Klamotten abgeben mehr geht
nicht ich bin echt echt happy Video ich
habe diesen Ort der ist richtig lieb
geworden weißt du ich wusste wann wann
ist hier Sonnenaufgang Sonnenuntergang
wann ist Ebbe wann ist Flut ich habe ein
paar Tiere hier die ich lieb gewonnen
habe ich habe so zwei große Vögel diese
die ganz lustig fliegen die immer
Vormittag sehr lang kommen ich habe so
einen kleinen Art Lego an hinten dann
sind Wasserloch immer kommt ey das ist
ja schöner Ort also wirklich mega ich
bin einfach happy
[Musik]
abgegeben
gemacht
mal gucken wie lange das geht dann habe
ich wenn du hier oben diesen großen
erdhang siehst ja da habe ich mir jetzt
meine komplette gerade mit Abschluss mit
dieser Kante ja das komplette hier drauf
ja aber hab nichts oben drüber gebaut
was ich da naja wenn es regnet
heute Nacht ja klar
20 m hoch
schöne Grüße gehen raus an Johannes
glaubst du wie viele sind noch drin seid
ihr die einzigen kommen noch welche das
glaubst du das ist so schwer zu sagen
plötzlich sind die einzigen
Bauchgefühl also mir die Hoffnung wäre
natürlich eine andere aber weil ich
glaube schon schwer fallen lässt also
klar für dich gesehen also hart für den
Automaten
Ultra ist harte das wirklich hart
ich habe gedacht heute Nacht im Regen
also ich fand es auch hart
ein bisschen daran dass man nur ein
Gegenstand Scheinwerfer Moskitonetz
mental dann dann wäre es kein Ding
gewesen deswegen so wirklich nur mit
Mama reden Voraussetzung fand ich schon
hart aber ich war nicht einmal irgendwie
gesagt habe ich spreche jetzt das das da
war ich auch keinen Fall aber ich fand
es im Vergleich zu stehen fand ich schon
hatte auf jeden Fall du das glaube ich
weil Schweden ist ja so hier sind die
Hitze die kann also das ganz viele
Faktoren machen immer
und immer viel Zeug ja ich war halt an
dem Punkt wo ich immer gemerkt habe ich
kriege nicht mal einen ringlichen
Shelter hin das war bei mir ein riesen
Punkt ich habe nirgendwo einen selbst
es gab es bei mir nicht es gab bei mir
keinen Platz wo ich irgendwie sicher vor
viel Zeug unterwegs war und ich habe mir
schon gedacht gebaut und mit Palmwedeln
und keine Ahnung was mit Blättern
ausgestorben aber eine wichtige Frage
gestellt habe hast du feiern bekommen
ohne Kraft genauso Punkt
[Musik]
warte mal warte mal nein
wie geil ist dieser Typ ja das ist
eigentlich die Bewegung die Bewegung
das gibt's doch nicht
was eine Legende Alter
will das gibt es nicht
wir gehen rein oder
krank
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt seit 4 Uhr morgens
ungefähr weil es geregnet
ich habe ja ich bin immer wach wenn es
regnet oh mein Gott ist das geil Alter
und dann habe ich umgebaut nach oben
sind da diese scheiß Alter
und jetzt bin ich fertig ich habe es
endlich geschafft
[Musik]
ich habe nichts gegessen nur fünf
Kokosnuss ich habe nur fünf Kokos süße
zwei waren Fleisch drin die sechs
zweimal Flaschen 5 habe ich also
getrunken zwei Fleisch die sechs habe
ich ausgekotzt
und hier kann man nirgends raus ich bin
hier eingesperrt habt ihr ich habe
keinen Weg es geht kein Weg raus da bin
ich einmal da hochgeklettert sind da
diese hält die Paradiesäpfel die dich
töten da bin ich wieder runter und dann
war ich hier unten
wirklich nur noch auf dem Fenster habe
ich ein Tod siehst du den Thron auf dem
Felsen der ist wie gemeint wie ein Stuhl
der einzige Stuhl es gibt sonst nichts
bei mir hat eine Wurzel reingesteckt
aber ich habe mir die Kit nicht
aufgemacht das war Tag
1,5
hier an der Seite runter
aber hier zwischen die Eier
meine Füße sind komplett verständlich
wie findet jemand hast du keine
Gegenstände abgegeben
und ich habe hier Hängematte ohne Dach
und dann musste ich wieder raus in meine
in meinem Leben Jacke unter die Palme
was bist du für ein Border man das wird
krank
unter ich habe dachte heute warum seid
ihr so spät ich habe mich am Tag vertan
ich mache schon wütend auf Johannes wo
ist der der wollte der wollte geben
Johannes
Kranke direkt beim Abholen ich habe
vorgestern meine letzte geraucht hahaha
Feuerstahl direkt an der Palme direkt
die Palme Zack und dann ging gar nichts
mehr für alles nass Bambus geraspelt
geil Bambus geraspelt
es war schön hier aber weißt du was die
schlimmste war
der Müll ich habe mich so
ich habe zwar zwei perfekte Flip Flops
gefunden
meine Schuhe und dann habe ich mir fast
immer die Knochen gebrochen du kannst
dir vorstellen beim Hochgehen ja hier
ist immer Flug bis oben und du hast den
halben Tag kannst hier nichts machen das
ist echt belastend gewesen überall
aber wir haben es er glaubt jetzt Fritz
hast du gesagt dass ich bis hier steht
ich wusste dass wir das Potenzial in dir
trägst das wusste das wusste ich von der
ersten ja aber das ist doch das geilste
Beispiel dafür voll keinerlei Erfahrung
kleines Training macht aber vom Kopf her
durch nichts gegessen
ey warum siehst du aus wie keine Ahnung
du kannst gleich einfach glauben
ich mache einen Tag länger als Fritz
haut ab Gottes
die Leute sehen immer
und jetzt pass auf du vergisst eine
Kleinigkeit ich muss am meine Hängematte
ein Platz suchen der nicht
lebensgefährlich ist weil überall und es
gab keine fast keine Option dass mich
eine Kokosnuss nicht erschlagen und
darum habe ich nur die Palme und dann
nachts fünf mal pissen und du musst auf
das Ding auf auf dem Baum raus so und
denkst ja jetzt falle ich jetzt breche
ich mir gleich und dann hin Verletzung
und dann kann ich durchfunken
ey du musst genau gucken aber schön dass
jemand bei meinem Sport was sagen
geil
ich habe einen kompletten und ich habe
eine Keule gemacht das habe ich mit aber
das ist geil schon ernst mit auf jeden
Fall ja
klar
ich sitze und denk mir so ungefähr jetzt
dürfte doch fliegen ist sie da seit wann
gestern
nicht Flug verpasst Reisepass vergessen
[Musik]
zwei weil ich ähm Situation Wetter hat
mich überfordert habt
wirklich gesagt warte warte
stell dir vor ich sag jetzt ich werfe
immer auf geht nicht ich halte der war
auch die Freude an nein
vielleicht morgen aber nein morgen ist
zu spät Feuerzeug der nicht an mich an
alle Hater die reingeschrieben haben
unter die Kommentare oh Nova und knossi
kannst vergessen Dschungelcamp Show da
sollen ich bin hier wirklich an meine
Grenzen gekommen du kannst es nicht
vorstellen wirklich und ich weiß gar
nicht ein einzigen Tag bei dem ich
gesagt habe ich gebe dir ein auf jetzt
habe ich nie im Singapur auch nicht ist
doch klar
und jetzt anderting
aber echt ich habe den wirklich den
schönsten rausgesucht guck mal die Augen
er ist jeden Tag habe ich ihm mehr Leben
gegeben
ich freue mich drauf viel Glück bei
einem von euch wird er im Wohnzimmer
stehen oder auf dem Balkon oder draußen
im Garten
und wandermut ich wäre fast da saufen
nein aber wirklich hast du es gemerkt
von oben ich habe mein Leben ist ich
mache jetzt echt keinen Spaß ist echt
damit vorbei gezogen ich habe aufgegeben
ich dachte wirklich ich sterbe hier bei
beiden weil dies war genau diese Zeit wo
diese Flut zu extrem und ein zurück ich
konnte nicht mehr wo waren die
Rettungstaucher wo du gesagt hast ja
super da brauche ich sie
[Musik]
ist Sascha oder
oder Yoga
[Musik]
genau
bist du depper ja
komm wir gehen
eine Woche ist vorbei
[Musik]
danke Insel danke für alles und danke
für nichts
[Musik]
bis zum Ende es ist gerade nicht
gefallen
[Musik]
15 Jahre Muskel
nein ich hoffe das Gefühl zumindest
scheiße
[Applaus]
[Musik]
alles drin
ist
Mädchen sagst meine Bucht hier die sind
alle schon beide jetzt seitdem seit 10
Minuten da sind viermal umgefallen jetzt
könnt ihr euch vorstellen wie es mir
gegangen ist sinnvolle Tage
meine Knöchel jetzt so viel Schmerzen
alles offen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier sind alle stolz in Österreich
müssen alles super stolz auf Dich
auch [ __ ] ja wir haben es geschafft und
jetzt holen wir vielleicht ab
[Musik]
[Applaus]
T-Shirt so geil Alter geil geil danke
herzlichen Glückwunsch Alter
krass ich bin gerade voll verschickt ich
bin voll im Film
wie war denn geil war richtig gut war
richtig richtig gut
ah krass Alter die alles zu sehen ne mit
uns mal zeigen wie du geboren hast
hey zeig uns mal deinen Shelter im
Prinzip ganz normale Shelter der Vorteil
war von mir dass ich dort hinten ganz
viel Fischernetze gefunden hatte
ursprünglich war der Plan dass ich damit
Fische fange Problem ich habe kein Feuer
angekommen ich Vollidiot also habe ich
die Großteil davon benutzt
ja so eine Hängematte zu bauen die hat
sich jetzt seit gestern durchgelegen
aber die war die ganze Zeit also übelst
Cosi richtig gut auch jedes Problem bei
Vollmond war hier alles überschwemmt des
Weiteren hatte ich nur Stachel Palmen
als palmwede das heißt die dort und die
dort und die sind zum Bearbeiten richtig
richtig schwierig weil die alle paar
Millimeter unendlich viele Stacheln
haben die gehen teilweise bis 5 cm
beim Arbeiten wirklich ich habe überall
spreißen drin in den Füßen in den Beinen
im Bauch überall auch nicht rausbekommen
hat sich alles entzündet
ja an sich
das ist mein Schalter hat ziemlich gut
funktioniert
da
macht eine Fahrt
bitte
geil geil
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Durchsage als Ehrenmitglied wegen
besonderer Leistung aus Staffel 1 wurde
ich dazu aus erkoren euch zu sagen dass
ihr die einzigen Überlebenden
Staffel 2
[Applaus]
und ähm
und Sabrina
gestern gesagt die erste Staffel war
verlängerter Buchstabe
im Vergleich zu dem Jahr für mich
persönlich da sieben Tage mit einer
Machete war einfach nur Abfahrt nicht
immer aber schon sehr viel sehr gut
ja es wird ganz toll du bist auch stolz
[Musik]
Pizza ich hatte einmal eine
Wahnvorstellung
voll da wo ist das beste
Preis-Leistungsverhältnis bei welchem
Menü von welcher Burger Kette
Mann
und danach hast du mich auf einmal
angeschrieben der kann deine Freundin
dazu warum du mich anschreibst nicht so
chill doch mal
da ist keiner man sieht Leute
[Musik]
ja so eine Blätter hätte ich gebraucht
100 %. ich bin drinnen
das ist für Kinder
besser
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Schatzi Zigaretten sind übrig alle
wegzigaretten
natürlich alle weg
ja was glaubst du denn
wenn schlechtes Wetter war wie soll ich
mich trösten
Doktor ich brauche unbedingt Behandlung
wegen Medikit wegen Punkte verlieren
habe ich mir die Kit nicht benutzt
kannst du das dann
mit Kippe machst du schnell auf oder was
welche Karte wo war mein Bild
wo sind wir jetzt
unten rechts ich war da ja
ein Bild irgendwie so hier unsere sechs
Kandidaten
sabrina war bei mir und Nova
die größte Scheiße
super egal willst kannst du denken war
hören alle irgendwie nacheinander aber
wenn du des Tages
über 10 km hier ja ja
gesehen
echt ja 247
Speicherkarte
alle da jeder hat abgegeben
[Musik]
ich konnte beides 20cm
3 Stunden lang gebraucht ich bin nicht
schon so oder
den Feuerstahl und den wassergrill hat
jemand anderes von euch gefunden
als Zeichen einer Abneigung
kontaktiere mich nie wieder lösch meine
Nummer
das war's
vorher ab 60
ja 62
75 ist damit habe ich 6 kg
was schätzt du sag ehrlich wir hatten
100,4 und es war immer 91,5
91,5 Kilo
74.7 oh ich kriege jetzt eine schöne
Kochsalzlösung wie die Superstars echt
wenn sie besoffen sind aber danach noch
ein Konzert haben einmal kopfsalzlösung
und bist wieder der alte ja da freue ich
mich
dahin
ein Video gesagt Leute schätzt eure
Möbel und eure Möbelhäuser wirklich ich
habe es auch ernst gemeint er hat jetzt
euren Stuhl
ihr schaut diese Show gerade überlegt er
diesen Stuhl tut den Stuhl was Gutes ölt
ihn ein oder macht was für ein Stuhl da
gucken wie ich hier sitze jeden Tag
ein Stuhl ist ja ihr habt das selbe
gedacht wir waren die Kamera gesagt die
eigenen vier Wände einfach das Bett was
man hat den Tisch schaut zu unserer
stell dir vor unser Bett daheim
jetzt habe ich dir gesagt dass
die Dinge ganz anders zu schätzen
besonders
kann das gar nicht definieren nach so
nach Insel einfach nach inselmensch ich
habe dich noch nie so gerochen wie
gerade so gar nicht nicht nach Schweiß
oder so
ich bin zufrieden habe damit gefunden
noch einen Tag bevor wir abgerissen
Späßchen gemacht und dann ist die
Situation echt da und jetzt sehen wir
uns wieder am Samstag
nebeneinander geflogen
aber ich kriege heute noch was
aufgeschnitten hier guck mal zeig doch
mal hier die wundervilla mir noch
aufschneiden ich könnte kotzen Alter nur
noch da steckt noch der Baum drin ich
könnte nur noch kotzen ehrlich
cool sein
geil wow ein Restaurant Aperol spritzt
jawohl jawohl
Schatz guck mal essen
einmal kurz zum erklären dass die
vegetarische Familie hier haben wir mit
Fleisch und einmal mit Meeresfrüchten
[Musik]
du kotzt gleich die überschätzt dich
auch aber maßlos
wir müssen zu Hause das Essen auf viel
mehr schätzen wirklich das ist so echt
so eine Cocktailtomate ne das
habt ihr irgendeine Erkenntnis gemacht
ich habe eine Erkenntnis ich sage dir
wirklich ich habe so keinen Bock gehabt
auf meinem Handy ich hatte kein so
Phantom so ich war froh dass ich kein
Handy oder gar kein bisschen Details
jetzt gibts Kohlenhydrate der Sascha das
schafft
du nicht
oder was
zwei Kokosnüsse 7 Tagen und jetzt gibt's
all inclusive gebucht da mache ich den
Teller voll
da kommt er doch
freut mich einfach mal normal
verkaufe ich noch den ein oder anderen
Mobilfunktarif mit Handy
[Musik]
so Prozess ist so du hast eine kleine
Abszess bedeutet eine Weiterbildung
durch die Fremdkörper ja das hat sich
infiziert Feicht habe ich mir Infektion
ist das wir werden erstmal desinfizieren
schön desinfizieren du musst keine Angst
haben dass wir den jede Schritt bisschen
Schmerzen machen aber das zu vermeiden
werden wir versuchen mit lokaler
Betäubungsmittel der gesunde Weichteil
bisschen schmerzfrei zu bekommen weil
wir der komplette infizierte implizierte
Bereich sauber machen müssen okay und
diese Holzstück was da drin ist ja
dieses Fremdkörper muss rauskommen ein
Knochenteil kann sein dass du verlierst
bevor das passiert nein ich sehe das ist
mein täglicher Brot deswegen und dann
zwei Tage nicht laufen
zwei vielleicht zwei Wochen Jens wir
müssen ungefähr
14 Tage kalkulieren dass du da
regelmäßig trocken halten musst
du auch zeigen
alles möglich ist daher brauchen ich sag
dir doch der Eiter ist doch dafür da
dass der Körper das von alleine raus
treibt die brauchen wir doch gar nicht
jetzt hier rumschnippeln seit sieben
Tagen hast du da drin oder ja dein
Körper dann ist nicht genug in der Lage
alles so mein Körper ist in der Lage der
Woche länger hoffentlich nicht nee ist
alles gut ich bin dran gewöhnt siehst du
das dieses grüne zeigt siehst du das da
oder grüne was da nicht sie hingehört ja
tut dir was weh nein oder okay so
nicht gesprochen
spüren und das ist unsere chirurgische
Set ja da ist kaltfeld drin einfach
einfach Metzgerei im Hotelzimmer
nach Material drehen rasieren
und noch zusätzlich Verbandsmaterial
wird dran kommen du bist Leidenschaften
kann man sich kaufen in der Schweiz und
du bist wirklich Arzt auch da nee
normalerweise Kfz-Mechaniker
nee ich bin wirklich ein
Arzt keine Sorge oh er ist auch Arzt ne
er ist auch ein echter Arzt oder ist er
irgendwie normalerweise
Samstagabend irgendwo drinne im Anker
und mit der Gruppe
man hat sofort Vertrauen
wirklich dann falsche Vertrauen
sorry
ich werde ich werde ungefähr in diesem
Punkt reingehen ja
der gesunde Bereich da werde ich Punkt
Knochen unter der Haut werde ich durch
die Fettgewebe reingehen von unten werde
ich alles auch so kann man sagen ja
reinspritzen dass die Wasser
infektionsmöglichkeit durch dieses Loch
durch die Fremdkörper Eingang rauskommt
und dann werde ich zirkulär alles
betäuben das wird dir in gesunde gesunde
weichteilbereich helfen nicht wurde
Infektion ist und das werden wir mit
eisbeutelbeutel genau und dann werde ich
danach laufen danach du willst eine
Verwandlung bekommen heute und morgen
eine kleine Pflaster morgen werden wir
Verband wechseln machen einmal gucken
wie das alles schon
normalerweise sollte gut sein aber bin
da kleine eitersemmelung noch Rest ist
vom Körper rein rausgedrückt wird dass
er ein bisschen kleine Hilfe brauchst
das für den Rauch rausholen wie kann mit
den sowas passieren ich will dich nicht
anlügen aber wir müssen schneiden weil
was da reingekommen ist gebrochen und
kann man von außen nicht ziehen und das
Problem von außen wird sich zusätzlichen
und dann hast du noch eine infizite
Weichteil wo eine so Abfluss braucht und
das hast du nicht von außen wenn du
Übersicht sich zusätzlich dann weiter
wird sich nach innen mehr weiter und das
darf nicht passieren
Spannung geben
also einer hat ich habe noch nie alle
die so weh tut das lokale liegt immer
weh oh junge
von der Wunde was da rausgekommen ist
das
ganz anders als Impfung
[Musik]
ein richtiger Stock so das war drin
boah [ __ ] zeig mir nochmal ich will mich
mal noch mal erinnern
ja das war die Wurzel dieser [ __ ] ey
du musst dir vorstellen das hat in
meiner Haut gesteckt ich denke Tag 1
scheiße
[Musik]
ich habe die schwersten Verletzung
meines Lebens
[Musik]
hey du hast es so wunderbar gemacht
wie kommt man zu der Leidenschaft ne
guck mal wie groß ist
wirklich großer
ja das ist genau dieses Stück Wurzel das
war von Wurzel und ich habe die Wurzel
rausgezogen und das ist drin gewesen
okay das hätte das hätten wir so nicht
rausgekriegt ich glaube auch nicht aber
du bist nicht so schlimm wie ich mir
gedacht habe
nichts gemerkt die Betreuung war gut
[Musik]
insgesamt eine Geisteskranke Produktion
ist riesig geworden ich bin mega mega
stolz auf das ganze Team bin sehr sehr
dankbar dass wir alle dabei hatten und
wir sind super froh dass alle Teilnehmer
umgeschaltet rausgekommen sind nicht und
dann kannst komplette Team und alle die
uns auf diesem Weg begleitet haben
sondern auch die Zuschauer die das
überhaupt irgendwie erst möglich machen
an die Sponsoren die uns hier begleiten
und wir hoffen dass wir ein geiles
Endprodukt bekommen wo wir alle drauf
stolz sein können
[Musik]